WAR.
BUT ANDREWS TELLS US THE KING
WAS MUCH MISUNDERSTOOD, NOT MAD
OR TYRANNICAL.
>>> BUT FIRST HERE'S "MY TAKE."
I HAVE TO CONFESS I FIND JOE
BIDEN'S UNPOPULARITY PUZZLING.
HE'S ROUNDING OUT THE FIRST YEAR
IN THE WHITE HOUSE WITH THE
LOWEST END OF FIRST YEAR
APPROVAL RATINGS THAN ANY
ELECTED PRESIDENT IN MODERN
TIMES WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
DONALD TRUMP.
WHY IS IT?
BIDEN IS A GENIAL, LIKABLE
PERSON.
MANY OF HIS POLICIES ARE
POSSIBLE, EVEN WITH REPUBLICAN
SUPPORT.
THE COUNTRY IS DOING REASONABLY
WELL, ECONOMICALLY WITH MEASURES
LIKE UNEMPLOYMENT DECLINING,
STOCK MARKET RISING AND INTEREST
RATES DEMONSTRATING.
SO WHY DID THE LATEST CNN
AVERAGE OF THE POLLS HAVE HIM AT
JUST 45%?
ONE HAS TO REMEMBER THAT BIDEN
IS SOMETHING OF AN ACCIDENTAL
PRESIDENT.
HE GOT ELECTED FOR TWO REASONS,
NEITHER WHICH HAS MUCH TO DO
WITH HIS PERSONAL POPULARITY.
FIRST, BARACK OBAMA CHOSE HIM AS
VICE PRESIDENT, WHICH INSTANTLY
ELEVATED HIM IN THE DEMOCRATIC
FIELD.
SECOND, DONALD TRUMP.
HAD THESE TWO FACTORS NOT BEEN
PRESENT, IT'S DIFFICULT TO
IMAGINE BIDEN IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
TO PUT THIS ANOTHER WAY, THE
PREVIOUS TWO TIMES BIDEN RAN FOR
PRESIDENT, HE DID NOT DO WELL.
HIS FIRST ATTEMPT IN 1987 ENDED
AFTER 3 1/2 MONTHS WITH AN
ABRUPT WITHDRAWAL BUT EVEN
BEFORE THAT, HE WAS POLLING WELL
BEHIND IN THE DEMOCRATIC FIELD.
IN THE SECOND RUN HE STAYED IN
LONGER BUT HIS POLL NUMBERS WERE
ABYSMAL.
A POLL RELEASED ABOUT A MONTH
BEFORE HE DROPPED OUT IN JANUARY
2008 HAD HIM AMONG 4% OF THE
REGISTERED DEMOCRATS AND HIS
SHOWING IN THE IOWA CAUCUSES
WERE UNDER 1%.
SUCCESSFUL DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTS
USUALLY FIT ONE OF TWO PATTERNS,
EITHER THEY'RE CHARISMATIC
OUTSIDERS WHO ENERGIZE THE
COUNTRY LIKE JOHN F. KENNEDY OR
BARACK OBAMA, OR THEY'RE
SOUTHERNERS WHO MANAGE TO BRIDGE
THE DIVIDE BETWEEN NORTH AND
SOUTH AND ALL OF THAT
REPRESENTS, LIKE LYNDON JOHNSON
AND JIMMY CARTER.
BILL CLINTON COMBINED BOTH,
WHICH MIGHT HAVE EXPLAINED HIS
SUCCESS, ACHIEVING THE HIGHEST
AVERAGE APPROVAL RATINGS FOR A
DEMOCRAT SINCE JOHN KENNEDY.
CLINTON IS TECH ANILY TIED WITH
JOHNSON, WHOSE RATING IN HIS
FIRST FEW YEARS AFTER KENNEDY'S
ASSASSINATION WERE SKY HIGH BUT
PLUMMETED IN THE LATTER PART OF
HIS TENURE.
BIDEN FITS NEITHER OF THESE
MODELS AND DOESN'T HAVE ENORMOUS
RESERVES OF POPULARITY AND
POLITICAL CAPITAL.
PERHAPS FOR THAT REASON HE
STRUGGLED TO INSPIRE AND IGNITE
THE PARTY AND THE COUNTRY.
NOW, TO BE FAIR, IT'S MUCH
HARDER FOR ANY PRESIDENT TO DO
THAT IN TODAY'S POLARIZED
ENVIRONMENT.
NO DEMOCRAT AND NO REPUBLICAN
CAN EXPECT TO GET MUCH MORE THAN
HALF THE COUNTRY'S APPROVAL, A
DIFFERENT WORLD FROM ONE NOT SO
LONG AGO IN WHICH OBAMA AND
GEORGE H.W. BUSH, BOTH GAINED
STRATOSPHERIC NUMBERS, FOUR
TIMES.
PERHAPS BIDEN'S DROP FROM 46%
FROM 64% IS FROM THE WEIGHT IN
CAPITAL.
BUT THE TIMING OF HIS SLIDE OF
POPULARITY, SUMMER OF 2020,
COINCIDED WITH THE WITHDRAWAL OF
AFGHANISTAN, RISE OF DELTA AND
ONSET OF INFLATION.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO PARSE WHICH
WAS MOST IMPORTANT BUT THEY SEEM
TO COLLECTIVELY HAVE HAD THE
EFFECT OF TELLING AMERICANS THAT
LIFE WAS NOT BACK TO NORMAL.
IN A RECENT "NEW YORK TIMES"
ARTICLE, NATE ET COHEN EXPLAINS
THE FLAWS BEHIND THE ASSUMPTION
THAT IF BIDEN'S PROGRAMS ARE
POPULAR, SO SHOULD BE THE
PRESIDENT.
SUCH THINKING IS PREDICATED ON
THE EXISTENCE OF AN ELECTORATE
THAT IS CAREFULLY STUDYING THE
VARIOUS PROPOSALS OUT THERE,
WEIGHING THE EVIDENCE ABOUT EACH
ONE, CHOOSING CAREFULLY AND
SUPPORTING THE POLITICIANS WHO
BACKS THEIR FAVORITE BILLS.
THIS MAY BE HOW SOME PEOPLE WHO
MAKE POLITICAL JUDGMENT,
SPECIFICALLY THOSE WHO CATCH
CABLE NEWS, VOTE IN PRIMARIES
AND ACTIVE ON TWITTER.
BUT ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE
REPRESENT A SMALL MINORITY OF
VOTERS.
AS COHEN NOTES VOTERS, BY WHICH
HE MEANS GENERAL VOTERS, SEEM TO
REWARD PRESIDENTS FOR PRESIDING
OVER PEACE AND PROSPERITY.
IN A WORD, NORMALCY.
TO THE EXTENT THAT THINGS DO
SEEM TO BE GENERALLY GOING WELL,
VOTERS TEND TO LOOK FAVORABLY ON
THE PRESIDENT.
TO THE EXCEPT THEY DON'T, THEY
TEND TO BE DISILLUSIONED WITH
THE WHITE HOUSE.
NOW, THE BEST SUMMARY OF THE
CURRENT SITUATION WOULD BE IT'S
COMPLICATED.
THE WORLD IS LARGELY AT PEACE
BUT AMERICANS CAN SEE THE
COUNTRY IS NO LONGER THE SOLE
SUPERPOWER.
THE AFGHANISTAN WITHDRAWAL WAS
AN UGLY REMINDER OF THAT FACT.
GROWTH IS COMING BACK FAST BUT
RESTARTING THE GLOBAL ECONOMY
AFTER A LONG PERIOD OF INDUCED
PARALYSIS HAS CAUSED HUGE
LOGJAMS AND HICCUPS FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS, SOME OF
WHICH CAN BE BLAMED ON BIDEN.
WE ARE SEEING MORE INFLATION
THAN IN DECADES, AND THAT HAS
OFTEN WEIGHED ON PRESIDENTIAL
APPROVAL RATING.
VIOLENT CRIME WAS UP NATIONWIDE
IN 2020.
AND THE PANDEMIC HAS NOT ENDED
WITH A BANG BUT RATHER CONTINUES
TO WAX AND WANE, CAUSING NEW
ANXIETIES JUST WHEN YOU THOUGHT
IT WAS SAFE TO GET BACK TO
NORMAL LIFE.
PRESIDENTS OBSERVE GET REWARDED
FOR BEING AROUND IN GOOD TIMES,
WHETHER THEY CAUSED THEM OR NOT.
IN JOE BIDEN'S CASE, HE HAS
MOSTLY HANDLED HIS JOB WITH
INTELLIGENCE AND DECENCY, BUT
HE'S PAYING THE PRICE